foreign
[Music]
decision transformation manager for the
California Department of Transportation
previously I was the data science
manager for the city of Los Angeles as
at the center for data science and
public policy at the University of
Chicago uh mostly about data Tacos Los
Angeles sunset uh Sunset photos some
architecture all fun times
um so here's the existential Panic that
wakes me up in the morning uh 50 of
greenhouse gas emissions in California
are currently caused by Transportation
your state might be slightly different
or country but it's going to be in the
same ballpark if you've been paying
attention to the ghg world at all over
the last decade and climate change and
whatnot you will know there's this big
transition of that did not was not true
in 2010. in 2010 the biggest emitter in
California was Power Generation
Um that sector is very quickly
decarbonizing you can Bank wind and
solar being really cheap
um
so you're like great hunter uh buy
everybody an electric car we got this
solved right and the answer is you are
wrong uh
I apologize but uh if you look at the
lifetime total carbon emissions of
Transportation electric cars are only
about 50 better and maybe if heavy
industry becomes Greener maybe they'll
be about 75 better than
um
you know conventional uh gasoline driven
cars totally fine this happens
um we have a plan for this which is we
have a Net Zero by 2050 plan in
California
um the idea is California needs to have
a massive reduction in something called
VMT which you hear thrown around in
those drivers stands for vehicles miles
traveled uh Transportation World much
like technology World filled with
acronyms I'm going to try to only use
the tech acronyms today
um so that gets us there and then so
California we wrote all these plans and
we established that we have to double
our Transit mode share in California by
2030 and then we need to five exit by
2050. and you're like great
um how do I take the bus
so looking at this
um I was actually going to ask uh show
of hands who like regularly takes public
transit
and this is like more than a lot of
talks I've given uh who takes public
transit and pays cash
like who has like some sort of weird
smart card that they have to load
okay mostly smart card users who gets to
just use normal people money like you
would go to a coffee shop
all right who
um who takes an agency that is like
super tiny like anybody take Dial-a-Ride
okay so long story short California you
might think is only three or four
Transit agencies you got like LA Metro
you got Bart uh there are over 800 uh
Transit agencies with over 200 agencies
offering fixed route service in the bus
so when you think about California Cali
TV was founded to answer this challenge
which is I want to go from Santa Monica
to Sacramento or wherever and I want to
be able to seamlessly plan pay for and
execute my trip uh we want to unify uh
transit in California with a common Fair
payment system so you're not like
juggling all those cards anybody who got
a Smart Trip card for DC just for the
week can uh can deal with that make sure
that you have real-time data
um on like where is the bus and then
make sure it's seamless to get uh
verification of discounts and whatnot
I'm going to try to present now that it
is not as loading and we're going to see
if this works
come on
yes there we go
and
all right
does not like me at all so we're just
going to keep going this way
um so the things that we really do to
make Transit seamless uh and I promise
I'm going to get to our stuff soon unify
the customer experience make sure that
we are
prioritizing sustainable modes of
transportation and grounded in equity
first so
how do you think about a Transit trip
there are three three parts of the trip
right so the first thing is can I plan
and get to the bus or the Train on time
um the next thing is once I get there
can I pay for it successfully and then
third uh in the United States we have a
ton of different types of Transit
discounts and benefits you might be a
senior you might be a student your
employer might pay for your trips
there's all sorts of things
if you think about California it is Big
there are tons of like Legacy systems
that you have to go interface with so we
have a philosophy of like Transit
technology needs to be like Legos you
can snap your fair payment system into
your real-time passenger information
system into your benefit system into all
your different CAD AVL subsystems and
whatnot
um we call a lot of this work on the
data front Mobility service data which
is all about providing uh so now we're
going to walk out on trip planning
providing accurate and complete
information for trip planning so
you think like what is the vision for
that
um it's that you have a complete and
accurate picture of what uh is going on
at any of those 800 agencies in
California and then when I pull up my
phone whether I'm in Humboldt County in
the far north of California or Imperial
County down down near the U.S Mexico
border I could find where is any bus
where is any train what are my transfers
how much am I going to pay in Fair
should easily show up on Google Maps
so the way we do this is we establish
clear expectations we assess every
agency in the state using automated
Technologies to say how well are you
doing this and then we provide technical
assistance to go meet those goals
so what is the clear expectation
um for California for those of you who
are Transit nerds you may have heard
something called the general Transit
feed specification formerly the Google
Transit feed specification this is the
thing that means Google Maps Apple Maps
City mapper Transit your R applications
can see Bus locations and bus schedules
in both real time and
schedules and then on the back end side
we also have a set of interoperability
principles for the vendors that piece
together these different pieces of
information to work together
assessing progress this is what's really
fun
um we take a look at all this data and
we produce in-depth assessments for each
agency being like Oh you you know you
didn't have trip information for 33
percent of your buses in the last year
uh in real time something like that we
talk to them every year doing like a
collaborative list of stuff we produce
monthly public reports on public transit
data quality and public transit quality
how how many jobs are agencies serving
how many folks are doing and we do this
for every one of the agencies in the
state that provides fixed route bus
service now and then we do NightLight
and we monitor this all nightly to make
sure that like when things Break
um for example right now school year is
ending a lot of Transit agencies are
changing service a lot of the smaller
agencies are not telling Google that
that service is changing which means if
you show up to the bus and they're using
an old version of their schedule you're
going to miss your bus so we really try
to make sure that that stays on tap
and then finally we do a lot of
technical assistance work across our
whole program we have a Transit data
help desk
um you know which has been really
focused on getting demand responsive
Transit into gtfs that's stuff like Dial
A Ride
um paratrans and whatnot we've built
Open Source Hardware and software to
produce gtfs real time to help agents
small agencies in rural areas to go do
it who can't afford more complex systems
we've produced playbooks uh and
documented Transit stacks for different
agencies and we do interoperable
development work all right so magic
Universe we've done all this work you've
now shown up the bus is here what's
about to happen
we need a new way to pay for Transit so
um you know from what we say paying for
Transit should be as easy as paying for
coffee customers can instantly know pay
tap their bank card tap their Apple pay
Google pay their mobile wallet and
whatnot
in order to do this you need three
pieces of Technology one's called a fair
validator second thing is called a fair
calculation software third thing's
called the payment processor this is
tied to the
one of the things I love about college
TP is we hate inventing stuff so we
really try to leverage Global standards
so this is how the banking system works
um I did not know anything about how
Banks Works before I started this job
and now I know perhaps a little bit too
much so
um
but rather than try to invent our own
custom flavor of how to cards how do we
take money do we need to set up tvms or
retail networks we just said how can we
make sure that Banks and you know
standard credit debit cards can work so
those three pieces of technology that I
mentioned are over here and they talk
between the provider's bank so this is
the state of California has banking
relationships and those go talk to
MasterCard visas toss your customers
Bank all of this happens basically
magically
um this is called the cemv standard
which stands for contactless Europa
MasterCard Visa
um and any Transit Agency in the country
can buy this uh we've done standardized
procurement anybody who's a government
person knows procurement is the worst
thing about government absolutely maybe
hiring is worse but pretty bad
um so we have what we call the mobility
Marketplace for
um
purchasing uh these types of solutions
and it's pre-negotiated it's like a
bench contract really easy and then on a
data side uh what my team can do is
because that data is standardized the
types of outputs you get from CMV Banks
all have been they've documented this
yes you have to transmit all the data
over SFTP but it is standardized it
comes in every day we can build merchant
services for these Transit agencies that
helps them understand their revenue per
day what type of fares they're getting
are people paying with cards or digital
wallets more often and that's really
focused on the transit agency's needs
joining that data with their gtfs data
Upstream to say like this route is doing
more rides what not in there
flip side of the problem in America I'm
going to talk about this very quickly
but we need to make sure that we cover
the on and underbanked we work with
different issue and partners it's really
kind of crazy but you it's much easier
to get accounts this is sort of grounded
in our Equity goal I could talk for a
much longer time about this but I'm
going to kind of speed through I'm also
going to speed through this that like
discount enrollments you want to
standardize and simplify we have a web
application if this was a Web Conference
that would talk about how we do all this
non-pii linking of people's identities
to stuff uh this is what it looks like
in practice this is the Sacramento Light
Rail you don't need a special card you
can just go tap your credit and debit
card it works really easily you get Fair
capping
so this is like the fun data nerdery
part we have 800 Transit agencies we're
stewarding like that is too many to
manage ETL processes for each of those
agencies so what we focus on is what we
call our core data sets which is we use
these three data standards to really
Drive our analytics processes so gtfs
schedule we do that every night we do
all sorts of different output analysis
from that data uh gtfs real time again
this is just like where is the bus and
when is it going to show up a stop we
get that data every 20 seconds this is
sort of actually gets to be big data
because you start talking about the Bus
location of every bus in California
every 20 seconds uh you can do that to
do like level of delay analysis speed
analysis where should how can you
optimize
um where to place potential
infrastructure Investments and then
finally our third standard EMB payments
two days after the transaction is when
it comes through and that powers you
know both our payments dashboard and a
lot of like traditional reporting type
work if you're familiar with natural
Transit database and stuff
so how do we do this again standard
standard standards simplify share your
resources so for batch processing and
data warehousing and share compute we
have a you know you know airflow
kubernetes and bigquery sort of Base
stacked uh all of our code and
documentation is open source so I
encourage you to go peruse it
um let's see do I have the doc site open
here
I do not have it open here right now
when it comes to analysis we tend to do
we have a Jupiter Hub we've been pretty
heavy users of Suba on top of bigquery
which is the DPI report for python
highly recommend checking it out
especially if you're there and then
finally for reporting and presentation
uh haven't adopted quarter just yet but
we do things like uh put together
um
all these sort of different reports some
of which are more lightweight but even
more complex this is a whole website
that is generated out of a Jupiter
notebook using Suba to give you gtfs
quality reports for all these agencies
so again web is a little slow but you
can see let's pick on uh big blue bus
that's Santa Monica California
and you get all this sort of information
and what's really cool about this is you
do not need a
um
analysts who has or a web a user to
speak about this is entirely generated
out of a python notebook uh that is
linked in there
um you can continue this is just some of
the elements you get in schedule
you get some you can do these Statewide
analysis of what is a high quality
Transit Corridor again this is looking
at all of Los Angeles's this is
something the state did not do and the
reason we were able to do this and if
you take one take away from this talk
it's the data standards especially if
you work in a distributed environment
are your best friend and even if they're
not perfect data you know exactly the
right data
when you start talking about gtf SRT
kind of digging in there's trip updates
vehicle positions which is exactly what
they say they are
again we kind of do this over and over
again so you can see here are live or
we're live screenshotted bus speeds for
Los Angeles Modesto and Oakland
um suffice to say there's a lot of
traffic
um but this has really been
transformative in how Caltrans does its
Investments because we can really now
focus in on this challenge of bus speeds
which is that some more
some more fun here's a fun chart of like
speed variability for an individual bus
route you can see that you know in
between certain stop pair combinations
uh buses have averaged as low as 10
miles an hour and as high as 35 miles an
hour which is definitely the Traffic
Engineers have their work cut out for
them uh and you can use it for like
evaluation of like okay here's exactly
where you need to drill down and you can
go from this big big Global Google Maps
Apple Maps view down to
Route 44 westbound in the afternoon Peak
is 5.5 miles an hour on this one thing
and we do it for every agency in the
state
um so all of this is public and online I
think I have the analysis site pulled up
so you can go browse these speed Maps we
publish this at our analysis site all of
these are linked in the chat here's
Sacramento again you can kind of drill
in all just static static Maps which I
love because we have no hosting stuff
um and that is Cal ITP that is like
using data to really Drive
transformative transformation investment
and operations
um I'll take any questions you might
have I realize I rushed through a lot of
that
[Applause]
[Music]